madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés
je suis heureux de vous retrouver pour
l'examen de ces deux textes attendus par
nos compatriotes
et qui visent un seul objectif protéger
le pouvoir d'achat des françaises et des
français
nous sommes vous le savez tous
confrontés à une situation économique
exceptionnelle
le retour de l'inflation
la guerre en ukraine
la désorganisation des chaînes de valeur
crée des inquiétudes profondes chez nos
compatriotes
et des risques majeurs pour l'économie
en europe et dans le monde
je l'avais dit il ya plusieurs mois le
plus dur est devant nous
le plus dur nous y sommes le plus dur
nous y sommes pour quelques mois encore
raison pour laquelle nous devons
maintenant accompagner nos compatriotes
avant que l'inflation d'ici la fin
d'année 2023 retrouve des niveaux plus
raisonnables
protéger économique pour les français
c'est notre priorité
nous sommes déterminés à le faire comme
nous l'avons fait je le rappelle depuis
deux ans face à des crises majeures
nous l'avons fait pour la crise du coc
vide
façade effondrement de l'économie
française la plus importante depuis la
crise de 1929
nous avons avec le président de la
république avec cette majorité mise en
place un quoi qu'il en coûte qui a sauvé
des dizaines de milliers d'entreprises
éviter un chômage de masse et aider
notre économie a redémarré plus
rapidement que les autres économies
européennes
la france je le rappelle a été le
premier pays de la zone euro a retrouvé
son niveau d'activité d'avant crise
grâce à la protection du quoi qu'il en
coûte et grâce à l'efficacité de notre
relance nous avons fait une deuxième
fois protéger nos compatriotes face à la
montée des prix de l'énergie en prenant
les premiers en europe et le plus
massivement en europe des mesures pour
contrer la flambée des prix de l'énergie
ces décisions ont été prises par le
premier ministre et le président de la
république il y a plus moi dès l'automne
2021 nous avons gelé les prix du gaz
alors qu'ils auraient dû augmenter de 50
% sur la facture de nos compatriotes
nous avons plafonner les prix
d'électricité à 4% alors que la facture
de nos compatriotes auraient dû
augmenter de
35% le résultat est là il est
incontestable nous avons le taux
d'inflation le plus bas de la zone euro
5 % c'est toujours trop mais c'est mieux
que tous nos partenaires européens
nous sommes maintenant au coeur du pic
inflationniste et il pèse sur tous nos
compatriotes sur leur vie quotidienne
sur les prix de l'alimentation sur les
prix de l'essence sur la capacité à se
déplacer à se nourrir à se loger à se
chauffer il est donc indispensable de
prolonger certaines mesures et d'en
prendre une nouvelle pour accompagner
nos compatriotes dans cette période de
difficultés économiques
nous avons donc pris la décision avec le
président de la république et la
première ministre de poursuivre
l'intégralité du bouclier énergie
jusqu'à la fin 2022 nous gênerons les
prix du gaz jusqu'à la fin de l'année
nous plafonnerons les prix d'électricité
à 4% jusqu'à la fin de l'année je le
précise il n'y aura aucun rattrapage
quel que soit le niveau de prix du gaz
quel que soit le niveau de prix
d'électricité sur la facture des
consommateurs en 2023 aucun rattrapage
nous maintiendrons également jusqu'au
1er octobre la remise de 18 centimes
d'euro sur les carburants et je sais que
c'est un sujet qui prête à la discussion
aux propositions nous avons fait des
propositions nous la majorité pour faire
évoluer ce dispositif
d'autres formations politiques ont fait
des propositions également nous sommes
prêts à les écouter
à les entendre à modifier nos
propositions si d'autres sont meilleurs
c'est l'esprit de compromis et l'esprit
constructif qui m'anime aujourd'hui et
qui anime toute la majorité la seule
ligne rouge que nous avons vous la
connaissez pas de baisse irréversible
des taxes sur les énergies fossiles qui
serait aussi dommageable pour les
finances publiques que pour le climat
mais pour le reste la discussion est
ouverte et j'espère qu'elle sera
constructive nous allons également
engagé des revalorisations
les retraites seront revalorisées de 4%
pour tous nos compatriotes après une
première hausse avec 1 1% en janvier les
minima sociaux seront revalorisées de 4%
après je le rappelle une revalorisation
de 1 8% en avril et quand je dis minima
sociaux je pense évidemment au rsa à la
prime d'activité à l'allocation adulte
handicapé mais aussi aux allocations
familiales car ce sont les familles qui
sont aujourd'hui les plus touchés par la
flambée des prix nous valoriserons enfin
le point d'indicé fonctionnaires de 3 5%
au 1er juillet nous mettrons en place
une aide exceptionnelle de rentrer et de
100 euros par ménage et de 50 euros par
enfant elle concernera huit millions de
nos compatriotes et leur permettra de
faire face à la flambée des prix
alimentaires
enfin les bourses étudiantes pour ne
citer que les mesures principales seront
revalorisées de 4% le ticket
universitaire sera maintenu à 1 euro
pour les étudiants boursiers voilà les
principales mesures de ce paquet pour le
pouvoir d'achat que nous vous proposons
avec le prison la république et la
première ministre elle représente
l'ensemble de ces mesures 20 milliards
d'euros dead supplémentaire à nos
compatriotes aucun pays européen n'aura
fait autant que la france pour protéger
ses concitoyens contre l'augmentation
des prix
toute sa mesure évidemment independent
de votre vote je souhaite donc que nous
puissions avancer de la manière la plus
constructive possible dans les heures et
dans les jours qui viennent sur ces
propositions toutes propositions
peut-être améliorer et la majorité sera
ouverte à toutes les propositions
constructives
simplement nous n'entrerons pas dans une
logique de surenchère nous voulons le
compromis mais le compromis ne s'achète
pas à coup de milliards
le compromis ne finance pas sur le dos
du contribuable
le compromis ne se construit pas au
détriment de nos finances publiques car
sinon ce ne serait plus la voie du
compromis ce serait la voie de la
facilité et la voie de la facilité n'a
jamais été celle de notre majorité
nos discussions doivent donc chang âgées
dans un cadre clair et comme toujours
j'avance en toute transparence et dans
la clarté avec les représentantes et les
représentants du peuple français le
cadre que je tiens à fixer cet
après-midi en accord avec la première
ministre est donc le suivant rien qui
puisse dégrader nos finances publiques
rien qui puisse ralentir la transition
climatique tout pour le travail voilà le
cadre politique que vous nous proposons
à l'entrée de ces discussions dans ce
cadre je suis convaincu que nous
pourrons élaborer ensemble des textes
qui rappe de répondre aux attentes aux
inquiétudes
parfois aux angoisses de nos
compatriotes enfin je voudrais dire pour
terminer que cette protection immédiate
nécessaire face à la flambée des prix ne
doit pas nous faire dévier de nos choix
économiques fondamentaux ceux qui ont
été chauds de la majorité depuis cinq
ans et qui nous ont permis de créer 1,2
million d'emplois en france et de nous
approcher en fin du plein emploi que
nous n'avons pas atteint depuis plus
d'un demi siècle l'innovation la
formation la qualification
le soutien aux petites et moyennes
entreprises la baisse des impôts voilà
la ligue économique est toujours été la
nôtre voilà celle qui restera de la
france et voilà celle qui nous permettra
de réussir dans la compétition mondiale
nous sommes maintenant l'article
additionnel
après l'article 5 madame le pen madame
la présidente mes chers collègues ont ce
combat et on ce combat durement ce
combat durement pendant les campagnes
électorales et c'est normal ça s'appelle
la démocratie ond ce combat durement
dans les assemblées et puis il ya des
moments où on est capable de se réunir
et je crois que s'il ya un sujet qui
mérite ce soir alors que nous sommes
combattus tout au long de ce texte de
voter ensemble c'est bien celui qui va
permettre la déconvenue gars lisation de
la hache cette mesure 2d conjugale
isation est
objectivement
terriblement injuste parce qu'en réalité
elle crée une double peine elle crée une
dépendance sur une dépendance la société
française elle cherche et elle le fait
avec bonne volonté à rendre un maximum
d'autonomie à nos compatriotes qui sont
porteurs de handicap 12 millions de nos
compatriotes sont porteurs de handicap
c'est extrêmement difficile et pour ceux
qui ont l'habitude de les entendre on
sait les difficultés qui sont celles de
leur vie mais créer une deuxième
dépendance kessel du salaire du conjoint
objectivement ça a été une erreur on
peut réparer des erreurs quand elles ont
été commises c'est le moment de le faire
nos compatriotes porteurs de handicap ne
peuvent plus entendre qu'on leur dise on
va renvoyer sa un débat futur à une
conciliation à je ne sais quel encore
une structure pour gagner du temps c'est
aujourd'hui c'est maintenant c'est ce
soir qu'il faut que nous votions tous
ensemble la dea conjugale isation de
l'allocation adulte handicapé moi je ne
veux plus entendre des personnes
porteuses de handicap venir me voir dans
la rue comme ils sont venus vous voir
certainement pendant la campagne pour
dire je voudrais me marier mais je ne
peux pas me marier parce que si je me
marie on me supprimera la location dites
handicapées tous nos compatriotes ont le
gros bonheur et ils ont le plus grand
bonheur que n'importe qui d'autre merci
beaucoup madame le pen
nous avons deux amendements identiques
le premier amendement numéro 4
allez-y monsieur le député
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement propose donc d'instaurer la
déconvenue gallisa sion de l'allocation
adulte handicapé une disposition qui
répond à une demande légitime et
répétées des bénéficiaires de cette
allocation mais aussi des associations
et collectifs d'associations de
personnes en situation de handicap comme
vous le savez le montant de cette
allocation est aujourd'hui calculée en
tenant compte des ressources du conjoint
ce qui a pour effet de pénaliser
270 mille personnes en situation de
handicap qui perçoivent de fait une
allocation réduite ou peuvent même en
être privé
l'individualisation du calcul qui vous
est proposé est de fait une mesure de
justice
synonyme d'autonomie de ces personnes et
qui fera de cette allocation un
véritable revenu individuel
7d conjugue la sdé conjugale isation
pardon qui vous a été proposé sans
succès à plusieurs reprises au cours de
la précédente mandature
viendra conforter le pouvoir d'achat de
ses 270 mille personnes dans le contexte
d'inflation et de hausse des prix de
l'énergie que nous connaissons mes chers
collègues il s'agit d'une mesure de bon
sens une mesure de justice
une mesure attendue de longue date
une mesure qui mérite que se dégage sur
sebha un consensus une mesure qui mérite
que la majorité reviennent sur la
position qui était la sienne jusqu'à ce
jour
monsieur dit que
l'amendement 792 monsieur breton oui
merci madame la présidente de ce
ministre madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues je m'associe effectivement à
ce que vient de dire notre collègue
dekker cet amendement vise effectivement
revenir sur un dispositif qui était
injuste je voudrais saluer le travail
qui a été fait au cours des années
précédentes au cours du mandat précédent
par les collègues qui ont essayé
effectivement à travers plusieurs
initiatives de faire évoluer les choses
je pense notamment à notre collègue
aurélien pradié je pense aussi à
stéphane fille viry et aux autres
collègues qui ont pris des initiatives
et je souhaite effectivement que nous
puissions nous retrouver ceci dit
derrière les unanimité il y a des fois
des différences et je crois qu'il faut
aussi préciser le sens dans lequel nous
présentons cet amendement c'est pas le
sens d'une individualisation des
prestations sociales qui reste sur
toutes les prestations sociales où il y
aurait l'individu qui serait seul face à
l'état pour nous le fondement de cet
amendement c'est la prise en compte
spécifique du handicap c'est dire le
handicap est quelque chose de personnel
et qui effectivement de doit être pris
en compte complètement par notre
législation on ne doit pas aller vers un
système complètement
individualiste de notre système de
prestations sociales je crois que des
notions comme la solidarité entre époux
par exemple reste des principes
importants dans notre droit et dans
notre système de protection sociale il
faut le rappeler mais là il ya une
situation particulière du handicap ce
qui fait que leur effectivement le
handicap c'est pas une situation
temporaire c'est une situation
permanente
on n'est pas dans une logique de revenu
minimum dans une logique de revenu de
remplacement par rapport à une
incapacité une impossibilité à
travailler et donc c'est la logique de
notre amendement nous ne sommes pas dans
une logique individualiste mais bien
personnaliste fonds prend en compte la
personne handicapée dans toutes ses
dimensions je vous remercie merci
monsieur breton
nous poursuivons nous avons deux
amendements identiques avec le numéro 8
est numéro 1017 je suis saisi par le
groupe écologiste nubes d'une demande de
scrutin public le scrutin et annoncé
dans l'enceinte de l'assemblée nationale
un amendement numéro 8 oui chers
collègues merci en raison du handicap
certaines personnes peuvent pas
travailler ou pas suffisamment pour
subvenir à leurs besoins aussi parce que
le marché du travail ne s'est que peu de
place aux personnes en situation de
handicap et donc il ya une allocation
spécifique pour ça la hache mais on est
en fait dans une hypocrisie on vise
l'autonomie mais en raison du seuil et
du calcul sur les revenus des conjoints
certaines personnes ne peuvent tout
simplement pas contribué au revenu du
foyer et donc en fait elles sont elles
doivent se tourner systématiquement vers
vers leur coup rejoint c'est souvent un
conjoint plutôt qu'une conjointe pour
toutes les dépenses de la vie
quotidienne est donc l'un vidy
l'individualisation de cette prestation
pour nous écologistes nous sommes pour
l'individualisation des prestations
l'automaticité des prêts ce test
prestation est en tous les cas là des
conjugale isation pour la hache c'est
une manière de mettre fin à cette
hypocrisie où on vise l'autonomie mais
on en privent les personnes qui sont en
couple et donc il s'agit de mettre fin à
ce dilemme entre être en couple et
poursuivre l'autonomie c'est aussi donc
une mesure de justice
je voudrais aussi saluer la mobilisation
citoyenne qui a mené finalement une
irruption citoyenne sur les bancs de
cette assemblée comme sur le sénat de
cette proposition mettre fin à cette
anomalie démocratique et donc je vous
invite je nous invite à voter largement
la dea conjugale isation de la hache
mais aussi à faire droit à ce droit est
à faire place à cette éruption citoyenne
qui a secoué nos deux assemblées
entendons cette mobilisation et faisons
droit à l'autonomie merci monsieur bayou
amendement numéro 1017
monsieur
monsieur roland mazurie
nom n'est pas défendu nous passons à
l'amendement numéro 480
n'est pas défendu
pardon les 10 mais madame madame la
présidente chers collègues monsieur le
ministre il s'agit d'un amendement
identique pour la dea conjugale isation
de l'allocation adulte handicapé qui
fait aujourd'hui semble-t-il consensus
sur l'ensemble de nos bancs toutefois
nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui de
calendrier précis c'est pourquoi
l'objectif est aujourd'hui de l'inscrire
dans la loi ce immédiatement que ce soit
dans ma circonscription mais dans tous
vous tous dans vos circonscriptions vous
avez reçu un certain nombre de
témoignages un certain nombre de
demandes justement c'est un phénomène de
société
ce cette mesure doit être voté
aujourd'hui puisque le gouvernement nous
a promis que y aurait là des conjugale
isation de la hache mais nous n'avons
pas de calendrier donc il faut la voter
aujourd'hui comme l'a rappelé marine le
pen
notre collègue marine le pen cette cette
mesure est défendu par le rassemblement
national ce depuis la campagne
électorale voilà donc cette je me
réjouis de l'unanimité qui est qui et
celle d'aujourd'hui et je pense que
l'ensemble les 160 mille foyers qui nous
regardent et qui vont gagner en moyenne
300 euros de pouvoir d'achat vont nous
remercier si nous votons cet amendement
faisons le il en va on est sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat là c'est un
geste concret faisons le ce soir
merci monsieur morin
amendement fait 168 messieurs vigiles
merci madame la présidente madame la
rapporteure monsieur le ministre la dea
conjugale isation de lâcher ça a été dit
est un sujet très important que nous
chez les républicains nous défendons
depuis très longtemps je le dis
clairement c'est une mesure de justice
sociale alors que le hc vous le savez
est versée à 1,2 million de personnes
270 mille d'entre elles vivent en couple
et sont donc actuellement
malheureusement pénalisé dans le cadre
du calcul de leurs allocations cette
mesure vous le voyez elle fait consensus
il nous faut donc l'adopter dès à
présent pour pouvoir l'appliquer très
rapidement c'est en effet une mesure de
pouvoir d'achat immédiate surtout dans
le contexte de très forte inflation que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui
plus largement la question du handicap
doit tous nous mobiliser avec une
attention particulière pour la défense
des droits des plus fragiles d'entre
nous il s'agit très simplement au fond
de notre dignité collective aussi je
vous appelle tu es simplement accepté
notre proposition
je vous remercie
merci monsieur ligier
amendement 69
madame antoine merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre dans
notre pays le handicap est un combat
quotidien pour plusieurs millions de
français et la république se doit d'être
inclusive pour répondre aux enjeux que
la réalité du handicap soulève pourtant
de nombreuses personnes gravement
handicapées avec un taux d'incapacité de
plus de 80% sont exclus du bénéfice de
la hache au motif que la personne avec
laquelle elle vibre disposent de revenus
supérieurs à un certain plafond cette
situation représente une injustice et
suscite l'incompréhension
voilà déjà plusieurs années que sur ses
bancs nous députés de l'opposition
plaidons pour 7 des conjugale isation de
la hache cette mesure et ça a été dit
avant moi c'est une mesure de bon sens
une mesure de justice sociale et pour
autant elle a été rejetée
à plusieurs reprises par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui le gouv l'exécutif se dit
prête à avancer très bien avançons en
conséquence dès maintenant nous avons
déjà pris trop de retard à cause des
tergiversations de l'exécutif alors
c'est ce que propose cet amendement qui
supprime la référence aux revenus des
conjoints concubins ou partenaires d'un
pacte civil de solidarité et ce dans la
détermination du plafond de revenus des
finissants l'éligibilité de la hache
merci madame antoine nous avons deux
amendes
nous avons plusieurs amendements
identiques nous allons commencer avec
l'amendement numéro 15
madame bruni va madame molina merci
madame la présidente madame un
rapporteur monsieur le ministre la
défense des personnes en situation de
handicap leur inclusion leur autonomie
est au coeur de l'héritage de la droite
républicaine
nous connaissons tous ici l'apport de la
loi de 2005 et l'engagement tout
personnel de jacques chirac en la
matière c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous nous sommes battus lors du dernier
mandat nous les républicains pour mettre
fin à une situation de recul
inadmissible en matière d'autonomie des
personnes en situation de handicap on le
sait c'est le conditionnement de
l'allocation adulte handicapé au revenu
du conjoint 1,2 millions de nos
concitoyens sont aujourd'hui dans
l'incapacité de travailler en raison de
leur handicap ou d'une maladie
invalidante et bénéficier de cette
allocation de 900 euros parmi ceux ci
certains ont le bonheur d'être en couple
mais en raison à du revenu de leur
conjoint se voient supprimer cette
allocation qui fait une partie de leur
autonomie on ajoute donc une dépendance
financière totale pour ces personnes à
une dépendance parfois physiques et
psychiques et c'est absolument choquant
insupportable il est temps donc
aujourd'hui de mettre fin à cette
anomalie qui contrevient aux règles
fondamentales de solidarité de notre
société à l'égard de l'autonomie des
plus fragiles je vous remercie merci
madame bolivar
amendement 223
non défendu amendement 236 nom de 123
nom de chartis messieurs 12 c'est une
jolie 236 oui merci la présence du
ministre oui depuis sa création en 1975
de location d'une handicapée et une aide
financière permettant de compenser l
incapacité de travailler de certaines
places handicapées aujourd'hui plus d'un
million deux cent mille personnes
bénéficient de l'ach dont 278 sont un
couple versée sous condition d'âge de
taux d'incapacité son montant peut aller
jusqu'à 900 euros mensuels pour une
personne seule par ailleurs son
versement est conditionné aux conditions
de ressources dans celle du conjoint
pour les places d'un couple or ces
conditions d'octroi se révèle trop
restrictive pour des personnes qui sont
dans l'impossibilité d'exercer un emploi
les plaçant dans une situation d'extrême
dépendance par rapport à leur conjoint
certaines personnes furent et le choix
de ne pas se mettre en couple pour ne
pas perdre leurs allocations et d'autres
nombreuses déciderez de se séparer pour
retrouver leur indépendance financière
aussi les associations revendique à
juste titre le besoin d'indépendance
financière des personnes en situation
d'handicap et la nécessité de
désolidariser des revenus du conjoint
dans le calcul de lâches cet amendement
vise à aider conjugue alizés
l'allocation aux adultes handicapés
en effet le mode de calcul actuel
maintient les personnes handicapées dans
une dépendance financière financière de
leur conjoint cette situation est
injuste et totalement contradictoire
avec l'esprit de la loi handicap de
février 2005 loi défendu par notre
ancien collègue jean fera chaud chaud si
en 2005 merci monsieur cinieri
amendement 241 allez-y monsieur députés
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chaque collègue nous avons tous
été sollicité par an dans nos campagnes
électorales par les associations et les
personnes concernées par ce problème de
décolonisation de la hache dans l'objet
de cet amendement est de mettre un terme
à cette cause égalisation
l'idée est également de revenir dans
l'esprit de la loi handicap qui garantit
aux personnes en situation de handicap
l'autonomie la liberté l'indépendance
retrouvée tout simplement la dignité et
une insertion sociale
le discours de madame la première
ministre discours de politique générale
a fait état notamment de la volonté de
la majorité du gouvernement de mettre à
l'ordre du jour la décolonisation de de
lâche donc j'espère que la majorité sera
attentive à cette proposition je
rappelle également que la revalorisation
de 4% qui est proposée restera quand
même en dessous du minimum de du seuil
de pauvreté et que c'est une demande
également que les associations les
bénéficiaires ont formulé d'avoir une
une allocation qui ce niveau digne voilà
je vous remercie si monsieur taupiac
amendement numéro 469
la présidente côté quand il ya quelques
jours nous avons entendu écouté avec
attention le discours de politique
générale de madame la première ministre
nous nous sommes réjouis très clairement
sur les rangs des républicains et je les
fais aussi à titre personnel d'entendre
la première ministre officiellement
annoncé qu enfin qu'enfin la dea
conjugale isation de l'allocation
d'adulte handicapé serait réalisée
rapidement
enfin dirais-je puisqu'il on l'a rappelé
à plusieurs reprises par trois fois déjà
dans la mandature précédente il y a eu
un refus mais obstinée et du
gouvernement et de la majorité sur le
sujet alors évidemment vous vous êtes
fait rattraper un peu par la brigade et
vous voilà revenu à de meilleures
conditions et tant mieux tant mieux
parce qu'aujourd'hui il ne s'agit pas en
réalité de revaloriser une prestation
sociale cette allocation adulte
handicapé ce n'est pas une allocation
sociale c'est une compensation du
handicap et il est donc important
qu'elle soit individualisé que l'on ne
prenne pas en compte les revenus du
couple on est dans la droite ligne de ce
droit qui a été créée par la belle loi
de 2005 même si sur un certain nombre de
sujets elle est encore bien incomplète
et elle aurait besoin et je crois que
nous pourrions en être d'accord sur
l'ensemble des bancs ici elle aurait
besoin d'être renforcée une société
n'est pas simplement inclusive parce que
la loi le décrète elle est inclusive
quand on vote à l'unanimité et j'espère
que ce sera le cas au moins sur un
certain nombre d'amendements tout à
l'heure la proposition que nous faisons
que d'autres faisons ou fond sur ces
différents bon alors voilà c'est le
moment vous avez chers collègues pour
ceux qui ont été réélus la possibilité
si j'ose dire de vous racheter il n'y
aura pas une autre occasion n'hésitez
pas faites le nous avons plusieurs
amendements identiques le premier numéro
allez-y monsieur le député merci madame
la présidente
nous avons depuis de nombreuses années
mené une bataille difficile sur cette
question de la déconvenue gallisa sion
de l'allocation adulte handicapé si nous
sommes les uns les autres au delà nos
différences dans cette assemblée s'est
certes pour défendre des concepts des
convictions une idéologie politique et
son noble respectable les unes et les
autres mais si nous sommes là aussi
c'est pour changer la vie de nos
concitoyens il ya peu de combat que nous
avons collectivement mener aussi
constamment depuis cinq ans nous sommes
quelques-uns ici de plusieurs groupes
constamment avec la même détermination
depuis cinq ans sans aucune lassitude à
nous être battus pour que la vie de
quelque 270 mille de nos concitoyens
puissent changer la première force de la
loi c'est de changer la vie de nos
concitoyens c'est de corriger
concrètement les injustices la seconde
force de la loi c'est de porter de
grands symboles au delà des 270 mille
personnes qui vont bénéficier de la déco
vulgarisation de cette technique là il y
à un message de dignité que nous
adressons à nos concitoyens au delà je
veux dire que c'est un moment
parlementaire sûrement important parce
que nous nous sommes battus les uns et
les autres pour l'obtenir parce que nous
n'avions pas réussi jusque là et que
nous sommes en passe d'obtenir un
résultat probant il faut aussi avoir
l'honnêteté de dire que tout le monde
n'a pas mené la même bataille oui c'est
vrai que la majorité de l'époque était
farouchement opposé à la déconvenue
ganisation oui c'est vrai aussi madame
le pen que vous n'avez pas voté la
dernière proposition de loi que nous
avons porté sur la d conjugale isation
mais aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un
moment plus important qui est celui qui
va nous permettre d'avancer concrètement
dans les actes monsieur le ministre il
faut vous preniez un engagement cet
engagement c'est que la réforme
s'applique le plus tôt possible les
seuls amendements valables sont ceux qui
sauvent les éventuels perdant voilà
pourquoi nous ne voterons pas ni les
amendements de monsieur bayou ni les
amendements de madame le pen qui sont
défaillants et qui font 47000 perdant
les autres amendements sont des
amendements qui installeront une vraie
juste ce monsieur le ministre engagez
vous à recevoir les gros politique pour
avancer sur ce calendrier merci monsieur
produits
amendement numéro 54
madame pires boom
merci madame la présidente
on n'est pas ici sur un débat technique
on n'est même pas ici sur un débat
financier on est bien sûr un débat
philosophique
séquelles quel avenir quelle société on
veut pour ces personnes victimes de
handicaps et là des conjugale isation
quelqu'un a parlé du prix de l'amour
c'est exactement ça c'est mettre fin à
une hymne et humiliations qui consiste
quand une personne est victime d'un
handicap et qu'elles bénéficient d'une
allocation de compensation de
compensation elle puisse voir ses
revenus diminuer lorsqu'elle se met en
couple donc aujourd'hui enfin nous
allons mettre fin à cette injustice
cet amendement 54 c'est l'amendement du
compromis et je vais m'expliquer par
rapport à tout à l'heure je ne peux pas
voter des amendements qui ferait des
perdants qui ferait des perdants donc
l'amendement les amendements
ceux qui sont scrutin public et ceux qui
sont identiques sont ceux qui permettent
de mettre en place la dea conjugale
isation tout en permettant aux perdants
de rester dans l'ancien système et cela
automatiquement remercie madame qui
répondent
amendement numéro 3 189
monsieur naegelen
merci madame la présidente vous savez
lâche est un sujet nos collègues l'on
dit depuis cinq ans depuis cinq ans on
en parle tous les groupes on en parlait
l'ont porté dans leurs dix
parlementaires à travers jeanine dubié
nous à travers avec jeanine dubié nous
nous l'avons fait nous l'avons fait
aussi est en effet malheureusement la
majorité s'y est toujours opposée alors
les temps changent les choses évoluent
sont 270 mille personnes qui ont un
handicap visite ou pas et à cet instant
ce sont des habitants de ma
circonscription une personne qui après
avoir travaillé 15 ans s'est retrouvé à
souffrir de sclérose en plaques s'est
retrouvé à devoir être en fauteuil
roulant est arrivé en retraite elle
touche 235 euros parce que son conjoint
gagne un peu trop c'est aussi ce couple
qui a 25 ans hésite à se pacser hésitent
à se marier tout simplement parce que il
a eu la mucoviscidose et que si jamais
il se met en couple eh ben ils devront 2
facto ils verront leurs revenus et leur
pouvoir d'achat fortement diminué et
dans le contexte actuel c'est
difficilement envisageable et des cas
comme ça on en a tous et toutes dans nos
circonscriptions alors il faut saluer et
je tiens à le dire on a tous critiqué la
majorité durant ces cinq dernières
années le fait qu'ils à chaque fois
refusées nos propositions de loi et les
différentes choses qui ont été portés
moi je tiens à saluer charlotte lecoq
madame madame la rapporteure parce qu'on
a pu travailler de manière collective
pour arriver à un amendement qui
regroupe quasiment l'intégralité des
députés de cette de cet hémicycle et
amandes et vous savez ce qu'on dit sur
les personnes qui ne changent pas d'avis
là on peut voir que la vie a évolué la
vie a changé et c'est dans l'intérêt des
françaises l'aîné des français et je
pense qu'on peut se féliciter que la
représentation nationale puisse
collectivement voulait démissionner
cette proposition de loi
amendement numéro 6 131
oui merci merci madame la présidente je
voudrais à nouveau insister
sur la question des modalités de la date
parce que ça nous paraît extrêmement
important nous avons fait plusieurs
amendements avec des dates différentes
mais avec un texte identique
c'est-à-dire qu'ils prennent en compte
la dea conjugale isation et le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas de perdants dans cette
affaire nous ne souhaitons pas parce que
nous savons que dans les années qui
viennent de s'écouler nous nous sommes
aussi heurter à un dogmatisme budgétaire
et à une mainmise d administration sur
le politique pour empêcher l'avènement
de cette mesure de justice qui était
qu'ils restent là des conjugale isation
donc nous voulons un engagement et c'est
à ce prix que nous retirerons un certain
nombre d'amendements éventuellement pour
essayer d'aller vers un vote le plus
consensuel possible mais nous voulons un
engagement de la part du gouvernement
pour qu' il n'y ait pas d'économies
budgétaires qui soit faite sur la date
de mise en oeuvre de cette dé conjugale
isation ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième c'est qu'il puisse y avoir un
engagement sur des décrets d'application
puisque qu'ils soient pris dans des
délais extrêmement rapides après le vote
de la loi pour que ça puisse rentrer en
vigueur rapidement et qu'on ait une date
butoir qui soit vraiment une date butoir
et que la dea conjugale isation puisse
être effective le plus tôt possible
sans mesures d'économies budgétaires
avec des décrets d'application rapide de
façon à ce que ce soit effective le plus
rapidement possible j'ajoute qu'on a
demandé aux caf de france des mesures
beaucoup plus compliqué au détriment des
allocataires je pense notamment à ce
qu'on appelle la découpe à la
contemporaine isation des apl qui était
quelque chose de compliqué qui a permis
de faire plus d'un milliard d'économies
sur le dos des apps elysées et qui était
très complexe à mettre en oeuvre et là
on a su dira aux caf d'aller très vite
donc si on est capable de dire aux cavs
d'aller très vite pour faire moins pour
les allocataires on doit pouvoir des
rockers d'aller rapidement pour fermer
en sont les
[Applaudissements]
amendements 694
bayou madame arrighi madame bateau
chaque collègue oui c'est une question
de dignité d'autonomie de justice
sociale et de pouvoir de vivre et du
coup on voit aucune raison de retarder
vraiment aucune au contraire il ya un
retard à rattraper et octobre 2023 c'est
trop tard c'est trop tard
438 jours voilà ce qui le sépare du 1er
octobre 2023 je vais être un peu cash il
a fallu que quelques semaines pour
baisser l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune pour les plus riches et on nous
dit 438 jours pour comme ça a été évoqué
par mon collègue peu pour que la caf
puisse organiser cette déconvenue
égalisation alors on nous dit qu'elle
est pas compétente mon collègue peu
vient d'expliquer qu'elle était
extrêmement compétentes est ce qu'elle
est sous-doté et bien embaucher et nous
vous soutiendrons mais on ne peut pas
attendre 438 jour plus tout le retard
déjà pris quand on est sur une
proposition un projet de loi qui parlent
de mesures d'urgence pour le pouvoir
d'achat pour de vie
merci monsieur bailly
amendement 829
messieurs ça venait de découvrir merci
madame la présidente
l'amendement que je porte au nom du
groupe horizon vise également à
supprimer la prise en compte des revenus
du conjoint dans le versement de
l'allocation adulte handicapé mais bien
sûr sans faire pour autant de perdre en
cette allocation est issu je le rappelle
d'une loi innovantes et de justice
sociale de 1975 voulu à l'époque par le
président valéry giscard d'estaing cette
loi considéré chaque personne handicapée
comme une personne autonome l'objectif
de la hache et bien d'assurer
l'autonomie financière des personnes en
situation de handicap cette autonomie ne
doit donc pas reposer sur la solidarité
familiale
mais bien sûr la solidarité nationale la
conjugale isation de la hache créer un
lien de dépendance aux revenus de
conjoint et porte aussi atteinte au
principe d'autonomie des personnes en
situation de handicap c'est pourquoi il
rompre ce lien de dépendance car il
conduit de nombreuses personnes
handicapées à renoncer purement et
simplement à se marier ou à se pacser
par crainte de voir le montant de leur
location diminué c'est une réalité que
malheureusement j'ai constaté dans ma
circonscription de la mayenne c'est la
raison pour laquelle je me réjouis que
cette mesure portée depuis 2010 est par
différents groupes parlementaires
une mesure de pouvoir d'achat face
aujourd'hui consensus au sein de notre
assemblée et je souhaite naturellement
qu'elle s'applique le plus rapidement
possible monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur prévenait clicquot
amendement 864 alesi madame
mon amour propre en prend un coup je me
sens comme un déchet de la société
maintenant vais-je devoir quémander à
didier le droit de prendre une douche ou
même de manger c'était le témoignage
d'angélique qui a été recueillie par le
collectif qui s'appelle le prix de
l'amour et que vous nous avons déjà cité
dans cet hémicycle à plusieurs reprises
parce que mesdames et messieurs et macro
nice nous avons défendu cette
proposition 6 x 6 x c'est énorme et ça
fait surtout beaucoup de temps perdu
pour les personnes qui sont concernées
par cette situation qu'ils vivent dans
leur chair cette injustice
et ce manque de dignité qui leur a été
refusé et pourtant je sais que vous n'y
auriez pas la détresse parce que vous
aviez reçu des lettres vous aviez vu des
gens et donc c'était vraiment une
question principe yale pour vous il y
avait un député de la majorité qui avait
dit ce n'est pas une allocation qui va
résoudre le problème du handicap
vous avez été long à la détente sur
cette question ce soir nous pourrions
discuter déjà de la revalorisation de
cette allocation au lieu de discuter de
la dea conjugale isation
mais nous y viendrons
et comme tous les groupes et je veux
remercier ici les collègues qui ont
travaillé à sa comme tous les groupes
nous allons soutenir cette mesure
évidente nous reviendrons à la suite à
la revalorisation c'est une question de
justice et de dignité merci madame
gaieté
amendement numéro 9 192 allez-y ne
dit donc monsieur le ministre adama
président de la commission madame la
rapporteure je crois que c'est un moment
important qu'on vit ce soir
ils sont rares dans la vie du parlement
et aurélien pradié l'a très bien dit
tout à l'heure où on essaye par delà
tous les bons d'essayer d'apporter des
solutions pour ceux qui vraiment
manifestement mérite cette attention
particulière
et cette attention non la portée mais je
voudrais dire aux collègues
parlementaires que le chemin ne peut pas
être fait seul vous voyez autres jours
en répondant à à la france a soumis je
disais que la co construction
on doit être capable de la faire entre
le gouvernement et le parlement on est
obligé d'avoir le gouvernement pourquoi
ça a été dit si on met en place à des
conjugale isation il ya quarante-cinq
mille familles qui sont perdantes et
comme elles sont perdants tu veux faire
quoi mes chers collègues il faut élever
le gage financiers et qui est capable de
lever des gages financiers le ministre
or olivier dussopt l'autre jour en
commission des affaires sociales a pris
des engagements et j'imagine qu'il aura
à coeur de les reprendre devant nous ce
soir et la deuxième chose il faut
atterrir revient sur ce qu'a dit
stéphane peut tout à l'heure à la date
la plus proche possible
d'ailleurs le gouvernement dans son
texte annoncé lé 1er janvie 2024 donc il
ya un pas qui est fait puisque on sent
la tire sur une même date en 2023 donc
je souhaite simplement mes chers
collègues que ces deux dimensions étant
réunies qu'on puisse avancer les
associations nous regarde les handicapés
aussi mais je fends d'un dernier veut il
ya un sujet qui traverse tous ces bancs
celle à faire de l'accès aux soins de la
désertification médicale et j'espère
qu'un jour on portera intelligemment
ensemble quelque chose qui apporte une
solution partout
merci monsieur vigier un manquement
numéro 1087
madame rousseau
défendu
amendement 1111
2 janvier
merci madame la présidente alors écoutez
moi je trouve que c'est un très beau
signal que nous allons envoyer ce soir
dans cette assemblée d'arriver à un
compromis sur un sujet aussi important
que celui du handicap et qui ça a été
rappelé a été porté sur l'ensemble de
ces bancs alors beaucoup d'entre vous je
parle de la question du handicap
beaucoup d'entre vous ont rappelé le
bilan est ce que nous avons fait et pas
fait durant ces cinq dernières années
donc je vais faire aussi notre bilan ces
cinq dernières années c'est une
augmentation de l'âge de cent euros + 12
% pour l'ensemble des bénéficiaires
c'est la réforme de l'abattement sur les
ressources du conjoint de réformes et
d'abattements supplémentaire de 5000
euros et ça c'est 110 euros par mois
pour sa famille est locataire c'est le
droit à vie et ça c'est aussi un sujet
très important pour les personnes qui
demandent régulièrement qui refont leur
dossier et on sait que c'est source de
complexité et d'anxiété c'est enfin tout
ce que nous avons fait en matière
d'emploi car oui c'est important il faut
aussi faire un virage inclusif et que
nous accueillons mieux les écoliers les
professionnels dans nos écoles dans nos
entreprises donc ça c'est sûr le bilan
de ces cinq ans maintenant la question
de la dea conjugale isation oui il faut
la faire et je crois que c'était le
résultat en effet de la mobilisation de
beaucoup de députés sur ces bancs et je
voudrais les citer car c'est important
jeanine dubié aurélien pas pradier
stéphane peu michel victory agnès firmin
le bodo yannick favennec bedo et marie
george buffet donc voilà je crois que ça
serait bien que nous finissions ces
discussions sur un vote de ces
amendements avec les solutions qui ont
été trouvé avec le gouvernement pour que
les 45000 personnes qui auraient pu être
écartée et bien trouver des solutions et
que nous atterrissons aussi sur la
question de la date je vous remercie
merci madame janvier
pas en 1122 madame parmentier lecoq
alors merci madame la présidente
vous avoir eu des débats intenses apr
des divergences c'est vrai et
aujourd'hui nous pouvons et nous voulons
avancer vers une solution co construite
collectivement
une solution qui permette la dea
conjugale isation et qu'ils fassent
160000 gagnant une
une solution qui évite d'avoir cinquante
mille perdant à 7d conjugale isation est
une solution donc qui passe par la mise
en place d'un outil spécifique complexe
mais qui garantissent la bonne situer la
bonne attribution pour chaque personne
l'évolution de la prise en compte de
l'évolution de sa situation sans qu'il y
ait de perdants cette solution à
nécessite un délai de mise en oeuvre et
j'insiste là dessus parce que au départ
la cnaf avait estimé au 1er janvier 2000
24 le délai suite aux discussions avec
le gouvernement et à la demande de
nombreux députés pour pouvoir aller le
plus vite possible nous atterrissons sur
le 1er octobre 2023 il y a des
sous-amendements à ceux à cet amendement
qui tentent de proposer une date plus
rapide mais ce sont des amendements qui
font de fausses des sous amendements qui
font de fausses promesses est donc
important de respecter cette date je
tiens à saluer la démarche de co
construction de cet amendement dans
laquelle se sont impliqués des députés
de la de quasiment tous les groupes nous
sommes donc dans une situation
exceptionnelle et je pense que cet
amendement mérité doit être adopté dans
ce sens et je tiens à saluer aussi
l'engagement du gouvernement par les
propos de la première ministre et par
ceux du ministre olivier du ca qui ont
permis de rendre recevable ses
amendements et donc d'avoir le débat ce
soir est donc de pouvoir utiliser un
véhicule législatif extrêmement rapide
qui permettra de compenser les délais
ensuite techniques de mise en oeuvre si
madame parmentier l'époque
sur le vote des sous-amendements 1146
1147 1148 et 1145 je suis saisi par le
groupe la france insoumise d'une ce mode
de scrutin public le scrutin est
annoncée dans l'enceinte de l'assemblée
nationale il y a plusieurs
sous-amendement le sous-amendement 1146
qui le présente ce sur quoi tonneins
monsieur rufin
messieurs rufin
enfin enfin le droit à l'amour pour une
personne handicapée
enfin il elle en finisse avec le dilemme
entre le célibat et la dépendance et il
en a fallu de l'endurance pour vous
ramener au bon sens à la bienveillance 6
x 6 x les pénélopes parlementaires de
droite comme de gauche ont dû remettre
sur le métier
cet ouvrage quel argument nous avons
affronté eu à affronter je cite c'était
trop technique il n'y avait pas le
logiciel adapté on nous a dit aussi que
le foyer la cellule protectrice de notre
société la solidarité nationale doit
s'articuler avec la solidarité familiale
donc y avait pas ça pour les personnes
handicapées que c'était extract est
ordinairement anti redistributifs voilà
tout ce qu'on a entendu et le dernier de
madame cluzel il s'agissait d'aller
contre une vision durable et
misérabiliste du handicap parce que la
somme était trop faible je veux dire
et aussi on peut dès 16h mandement c'est
pour aller plus loin dans la démarche
qui va nous réunir ce soir mais il ya du
bon sens dans ce que dit madame plus
cluzel contre cette somme qui est trop
faible il ya aujourd'hui un nouveau
scandale qu'il nous faut résoudre c'est
quoi comment peut on avoir une
allocation adulte handicapé qui se
trouve sous le seuil de pauvreté
lâche est à 920 euros le seuil de
pauvreté est à 1109 euros moi j'aurais
tendance à dire que ces personnes ne
peuvent pas travailler c'est prouvé par
la médecine en l'occurrence si elles si
elles bénéficient de cette allocation et
que du coup ça devrait aller jusqu'à la
hauteur du suite mais le minimum serait
le seuil de pauvreté et enfin le
deuxième point madame la première
ministre est venu nous dire que c'était
une question de dignité il faut dire ce
qui est c'est que pendant 7 5 années
vous avez maintenu une indignité il est
temps on a trop attendu
on peut pas attendre jusqu'au octobre
2023 les personnes en situation de
handicap ne peuvent pas attendre jusque
là il faut que ça soit réglé avant et si
ça n'est pas réglée avant il faut un
effet rétroactif merci monsieur un
amendement sous amendement numéro 1147
merci merci madame la présidente
monsieur queyranne ici on aurait pu
demander la rétroactivité des droits
depuis 2021 quand vous avez dénaturer la
proposition de descons jugule isation
effet un vote bloqué et donc lutter
contre la dignité on aurait pu aussi le
faire en rappelant 2019 ou 2018 quand
vous avez refusé les propositions de loi
des groupes de tous les groupes que ça
soit l'âge et dr
ler ps et insoumis et on aurait pu aller
jusqu'en 1975 où cette première
injustice de base a été mis en place
on a perdu cinq ans à cause de vous cinq
années ont été perdus et vous venez nous
dire que maintenant il faudra encore un
an de plus un an et demi de plus
donc soyez heureux nous vous proposons à
votre fameux compromis novembre 2022
nous vous demandons la rétroactivité des
droits depuis novembre a juste depuis
novembre 2022
car cette aberration comme emmanuel
macron l'a dit lui même
il a lui même reconnu lors du débat du
second tour il faut que vous mettiez la
main à la poche maintenant et ce n'est
pas ce n'est qu'une justice pour les
personnes en situation de handicap donc
réparer votre aberration
merci monsieur pierre brard
un sous-amendement numéro 1 848
madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues c'est une décision
extrêmement importante
quelquefois quelque chose de solennel
deux signataires de cet amendement
[Musique]
c'est monsieur rufin monsieur kerbrat
surpoids tonneins
[Musique]
monsieur k tenace je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente
quand on est une personne en situation
de handicap on est en situation de
handicap que l'on ait ou pas un conjoint
à six reprises par le passé nous vous
l'avons rappelé nous avons demandé cette
dé conjugale isation elle nous a été
refusée avec des arguments irrecevables
aujourd'hui nous avons perdu trop de
temps et les personnes en situation de
handicap elles ont perdu trop d'argent
aussi désormais nous pensons qu'il faut
aller le plus vite possible on nous
parle d' octobre 2023 c'est beaucoup
trop tardive pour les bénéficiaires cela
a été dit par certains collègues pour
faire la suppression de l' isf pour
baisser les apl un claquement de doigts
a suffi qu'il faille bien sûr quelques
mois de paramétrage tout cela est bien
sûr entendable mais ce doit être des bus
2023 et pas plus tard rien ne
justifierait d'attendre octobre 2023
surtout dans un contexte d'inflation et
de hausse des prix est de plus comme
l'ont dit certains collègues il faut non
seulement des conjugue alizés mais
également revalorisée dernier point
madame la présidente certains
amendements sont malheureusement mal
rédigée et ferait des perdants qui en
effet sont celles et ceux qui
travaillent et dont le conjoint n'a pas
ou peu de ressources cela concerne 44
mille personnes selon les estimations
sur 270 milles allocataires de
l'allocation adulte handicapé aussi je
demande à madame le pen madame ménard et
d'autres collègues de faire comme
d'autres ont fait sur les bancs de
retirer leur amendement mal rédigé qui
ferait des perdants dans le cas où il
était adopté
merci le supporter n 1
nous avons le sous-amendement 1145
défendu
l'amendement numéro 150 de
monsieur ne d'air madame bonnivard
défendu très bien
amendement numéro 678
défendu
quel est l'avis de la commission s'il
vous plaît sur les amendements il est
sous amendement
merci même la présidente
la commission peut être pour rappeler
là où nous en étions arrêtés dans lors
des travaux de la commission au stade de
la commission il n'avait été possible
que de déposer des amendements qui
permettait la dea conjugale isation
sèche c'est à dire sans prendre en
compte la situation des 45000 personnes
qui auraient été perdante il a été
décidé collectivement lors de la
commission de retirer ses amendements
pour pouvoir avancer dans la
construction d'une solution collective
pardon qui permettent de faire la
déconvenue galles isation d'éviter qu'il
y ait des perdants de garantir un
système qui répondent notamment aux
différentes préoccupations qui ont été
soulevés comme s'assurer que la
situation l'évolution de la situation
des personnes puissent bien être prises
en compte
cette solution collective nous avons
réussi à la construire et c'est l'objet
des amendements identiques vous nous
venons de présenter
la question qui porte encore débat
discussion et ça a été dit plusieurs
fois c'est la question de la date de
mise en oeuvre cette date elle est
vraiment importante puisque chacun de
nous souhaite que cette solution puisse
être mise en oeuvre le plus rapidement
possible et c'est pourquoi utiliser ce
véhicule législatif nous permet
d'envoyer un signal fort de volonté
d'agir le plus rapidement possible
ensuite il y à des questions des
considérations techniques et le ministre
va y répondre je pense assez précisément
qui nécessite un délai de mise en oeuvre
donc aujourd'hui nous avons trois 3
choix finalement parmi les amendements
qui nous ont été présentés
le premier choix c'est choisir les
amendements comme celui de madame le pen
qui permettent la déconvenue égalisation
sèche mais qui font des perdants
évidemment sur ces amendements je
donnerai un avis défavorable
le deuxième choix c'est celui 2 choisir
des amendements qui proposent la
déconvenue gallisa sion mais avec des
délais plus proche que celui du 1er
octobre ce sont des amendements qui ne
sont pas vraies liste on peut l'appeler
de nos voeux on peut faire des tas de
prémonition l'amendement que nous avons
déposés à la quasi totalité des groupes
il est basé sur une réflexion solide il
est basé sur des éléments qui nous ont
été apportés par la cnaf dire que d'un
claquement de doigts on pourra leur
faire aller plus vite que ce qu'ils ont
proposé est faux donc il ne faut pas
aller vers ces amendements je donnerai
aussi un avis défavorable puisqu'il ne
faut pas faire de fausses promesses à
nos concitoyens
il nous reste donc un troisième choix
qui est celui de voter
collectivement les amendements que la
quasi-totalité des groupes ont déposé
l'amendement identique c'est-à-dire les
amendements je reprends précisément les
numéros les amendements 3 à 1122 dans la
discussion que nous venons d'avoir donc
c'est un avis évidemment favorable sur
ces amendements ce sera un avis
défavorable sur les quatre sous
amendement qui lecture qui les
concernent puisque ces sous amendements
proposent des dates d'application qui ne
sont pas réalistes et qui font de
fausses promesses donc avis défavorable
sur ces quatre sous amendements
favorables
évidemment sur les trois amendes sur les
amendements pardon identique co
construit collectivement et déposé par
la quasi-totalité des groupes et avis
défavorable pour tous les autres
amendements qui ne répondent pas à
l'objectif de des conjugue alizés le
plus vite possible sans faire de
perdants nous allons procéder au scrutin
pour les amendes en 3 identique avis
favorable commission et gouvernement le
scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votants 429 exprimés 420 9 majorité 215
pour 428 contre 1 adoptée
[Applaudissements]
nous en avons terminé avec l'examen des
amendements je vous rappelle que la
conférence des présidents a décidé qu'il
serait procédé à un scrutin public sur
le projet de loi je fais d'ores et déjà
annoncé le scrutin public dans
l'enceinte de l'assemblée nationale j'ai
des demandes d'explications de vote par
les groupes monsieur pierre dharréville
madame la présidente chères et chers
collègues il ya beaucoup d'attentes
il y avait beaucoup d'attenté y aura
beaucoup de désillusions vous aviez
annoncé une loi exceptionnelle sur le
pouvoir d'achat c'est une loi vite des
mesures nécessaires c'est une loi
d'affichage c'est une loi qui fait
semblant c'est aussi une loi qui porte
des germes toxiques ce que nous dit ce
texte que vous ne voulez pas changer de
cap vous voulez continuer à jouer la
modération salariale pour l'immense
majorité vous voulez faire de la france
un pays de bas salaires vous voulez
faire des salariés de notre pays des
travailleurs les travailleuses pour
beaucoup mal rémunérés mal protégé
voulait faire de notre pays un nouveau
champion du travail qui ne coûtent pas
cher vous voulez la rémunération
précaire en modifiant la structure même
de la rémunération du travail
moins de salaires et de cotisations
assises sur des cadres collectifs plus
de rémunération aléatoire et
discrétionnaire
selon vous pour lutter contre le chômage
il faut des salaires pas trop élevé
ajoutons-y des licenciements facile et
des droits à l'assurance chômage réduit
c'est le salaire de la peur du lendemain
vous prétendez qu'augmenter les salaires
alimenterait l'inflation comment
expliquez vous alors cette explosion des
prix qui n'a pas attendu la guerre en
ukraine alors que les salaires c'est peu
de le dire n'ont connu aucune explosion
de leur côté c'est la spéculation ce
sont les profits ce sont les dividendes
c'est la finance ce sont les inégalités
qui fabrique l'inflation certains nous
disent c'est la vie c'est le destin
ainsi va le monde et le monde va mal
jamais nous nous habitue rond au mépris
du travail des ouvriers des employés des
salariés qui plus est tandis que par
exemple les patrons du cac40 voient leur
rémunération multiplié par deux en un an
ce que met en lumière l'aggravation du
moment c'est l'urgence d'intervenir pour
assainir une situation inacceptable ou
les richesses produites sont accaparés
par une poignée de puissants qui savent
les utiliser à rebours de l'intérêt des
humains de la planète pendant ce temps
là vous mégoter sur le smic vous êtes
rattrapez-vous même pas les mécanismes
de sauvegarde automatique minimaliste et
vous feignez d'en être les instigateurs
on vit mal avec le smic on a du mal à se
nourrir à se chauffer à se loger à se
déplacer à se cultiver on a du mal à
faire des choix on subit sa vie et c'est
sur ce terreau que vous venez ensuite
vous présenter en sauveur avec des
rémunérations complémentaires qui
ressemble à du pourboire avec des
incitations à faire des heures
supplémentaires qui viendront pour s'en
sortir on doit pouvoir vivre dignement
de son travail pour nous
pour nous ici sur ces bancs il y à de la
colère à vous voir manoeuvrer pour
éviter une autre répartition des
richesses en faisant tout pour ne
surtout pas augmenter les salaires dites
nous combien de femmes et d'hommes
bénéficieront de ce déplafonnement de
cette mesure aléatoire donnez-nous
l'addition également pour la sécurité
sociale dans ce texte vous multipliez
encore les exonérations de cotisations
sociales vous effacez d'une certaine
façon cette part du salaire qui
constituent des droits solidaire à la
protection sociale mais vous viendrez
ensuite nous expliquer qu'il faut
réduire ces droits vous viendrez ensuite
nous expliquer qu'on ne peut pas trop
augmenter les pensions par exemple et
pour cause ou vous priver des moyens de
le faire et les augmentations de pension
et de minima sociaux que vous proposez
insuffisantes sont comme un avaloir
prise sur la suite entendez donc
entendez ces hommes et surtout ces
femmes qui vivent difficilement avec
leur pension de retraite parce qu'on a
pendant si longtemps gelé le point
d'indicé entendez ces familles qui ont
de plus en plus de mal à se loger et à
payer leur loyer qu'il faudrait geler
l'inflation galope et vous marcher au
pas loin derrière avec non seulement des
mesures insuffisantes
mais au-delà de cela
pardonnez-moi des mesures également
qu'ils sont nocives et avec rien
strictement rien pour prendre la mesure
des difficultés encore plus considérable
nos concitoyennes et concitoyens d outre
mer heureusement mince tentative de
rachat vous avez consentis à des
conjugue alizés l'allocation aux adultes
handicapés mais c'est bien peu face
l'ampleur des problèmes du quotidien à
quoi vous ajoutez une politique
énergétique
qui finalement contribué à continuer
d'affaiblir edf nous voulons vivre bien
voilà ce que dit le pays nous avons
multiplié les propositions en ce sens
notre vote ce matin se veut un coup de
semonce un signal d'alarmé un appel
retentissant vous avez dix jours pour
enfin choisir d'agir vraiment pour
construire cette loi que nous appelons
de nouveau les canaris ne trouveraient
toujours disponible mais pour vous
accompagner dans une politique qui a
déjà produit tant de dégâts vous nous
trouverez toujours en face c'est
pourquoi ils ne soutiendront pas cette
version de la loi vous remercie monsieur
cloud et pour la pause est soumise
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente collègues ministres
si nous parlons aujourd'hui pouvoir
d'achat c'est que six millions et demi
de nos compatriotes ont voté pour la
nuque aux élections législatives
obligeant le gouvernement à se saisir du
sujet
sans ces six millions et demi de voix le
gouvernement serait en train ce soir d'
essayer de repousser l'âge de départ en
retraite et la colère partout dans le
pays vous a obligé à lâcher du lest
allocation adulte handicapé des conjugue
alizés après s'ils refusent fin des
compléments de loyers pour les
locataires d'un logement humide droit
d'annuler un abonnement par voie
électronique
autant de victoire populaire le peuple
vous a tordu le bras et il a bien fait
mais pourquoi discutons nous ce soir de
mesures d'urgence et bien à cause de
votre bilan car le gel des salaires
c'est vous depuis 2010 est les 1% les
plus riches ont gagné 3500 euros par an
tandis que les 1% les plus pauvres
perdent et 50 euros
la hausse des prix c'est vous aussi
parce que le laisser faire c'est un
choix accepter qu'à conditions
techniques inchangé le transport
pétrolier explose c'est un choix vous
laissez faire les profiteurs qui
augmentent les prix et qui s'engraissent
le cours des céréales par exemple est
tenu par une poignée de spéculateurs les
deux tiers étranger au secteur agricole
et qui veulent juste passé moi
l'expression se faire du blé bilan dans
le caddie
17 % d'augmentation du prix des pâtes 14
% de hausse du prix de l'huile 3% pour
les télécoms et dans votre texte vous
organisez vous même une augmentation de
trois et demi pour cent des loyers nous
sommes le parti du blocage des prix vous
êtes le parti de l'inflation organisé et
délibéré
et vous profitez de cette spirale
inflationniste pour tenter maintenant de
nous faire les poches car tout ce projet
est une déclaration de guerre aux
salaires vous refusez le smic à 1500
euros vous refusez les salaires indexés
sur les prix votre projet n'emploie que
deux mots la prime et l'intéressement
pourquoi car partout où on les adopte
partout on les met en oeuvre les
salaires sont gelés la prime c'est votre
arme contre les hausses de salaire exigé
partout dans le pays par les syndicats
les salariés concernés vont donc devoir
travailler plus pour gagner peut-être
quant au peu que vous nous donnez il est
pris sur ce que vous nous devez ce que
vous nommez les revalorisations anticipé
mais nous ne sommes pas au bout de nos
peines car le gouvernement compte aussi
nous faire payer sur 30 ans
toutes ces primes tous et intéressement
ont un point commun ils sont exonérés de
cotisations sociales un euro touché
c'est zéro euro pour les caisses de
retraite c'est zéro euro pour les
caisses de l'assurance maladie et voici
donc nos bons gestionnaires qui
volontairement mettre en déficit de la
sécurité sociale
une fois une fois les comptes dans le
rouge vous nous expliquerez qu'il faut
entamer une réforme des retraites ou
qu'il faut une nouvelle fois coupé les
droits des chômeurs pourtant à des
dizaines de reprises dans ce débat nous
vous avons proposé de soumettre à
cotisations un ensemble de revenus nous
condition les 20 milliards d'euros
d'exonérations de cotisations sociales
accaparé par les plus grandes
entreprises du pays
ce qui représente pas moins de 350 euros
par française et trans est versé à nos
propres employeurs les conditions que
nous mettions sur la table pouvait être
la hausse des salaires l'égalité
femmes-hommes ou même l'absence de
présence en paradis fiscal mais il n'y a
plus dans ce pays aucune horreur que
puisse commettre une multinationale pour
ne pas ça pour s'attirer vos foudre
ainsi avec vous ce n'est plus uniquement
un parlement ici c'est un conseil
d'administration géant qui jouent avec
l'argent des français
et tout cela sans compter la dernière
facture que vous nous réservez pour
plusieurs générations
la facture climatique vous êtes obligé
de reconnaître l'échec du marché votre
texte parle d'état de réquisition et
d'obligations mais comme toujours avec
un seul objectif
collectiviser les pertes et privatiser
les profits votre projet jette les
règles environnementales par dessus bord
au profit de l'énergie fossile d'une
part pour faciliter la construction d'un
terminal dédié à l'importation du gaz de
schiste étasunien affranchi de toute
étude d'impact au nom du pouvoir d'achat
en autorise deux géants financiarisé à
construire des infrastructures sans
aucun contrôle environnemental
comme quoi dans ce pays se revendiquent
de l'essence pas cher on finit éborgné
mais lorsqu'on veut faire des supers
profits gazier on obtient la protection
immédiate du gouvernement texte de loi
la pluie
d'autre part vous relancer des centrales
à charbon dangers écologiques le plus
beau couleur ou clear niche il ya quinze
jours elisabeth bande clamé nous serons
la première nation à sortir des énergies
fossiles voici ce que valent les
engagements riant voilà pourquoi il ne
les députés de données
[Applaudissements]
la parole est un monsieur le sol pour le
socialiste et apparentés
[Applaudissements]
merci merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre
je suis re collègues
je serais bref
[Applaudissements]
le projet de loi je serais bref mais
laissez moi quand même dire quelques
mots le projet de loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat
malheureusement est loin très très loin
de l'ambition que son titre laisse
supposer il comporte des mesures visant
à faire face aux difficultés
d'approvisionnement en gaz et en
électricité nous en avons parlé tout à
l'heure dans un contexte national d'une
très faible disponibilité de notre parc
électronucléaire
d'une trop grande insuffisance du
développement des nerfs
si notre groupe peut partager la
nécessité de dispositif exceptionnel et
limité dans le temps nous avons trop de
mesures dérogatoires aux objectifs de
protection de l'environnement et peu de
mesures permettant d'envisager une
sérieuse autonomie énergétique
ce texte décousu sans grande cohérence
comporte des mesures économiques de
consommation souvent sans caractère
d'urgence malheureusement est sans effet
immédiat sur le pouvoir d'achat beaucoup
de ces mesures n'ont pas de pérennité
bien sûr nous félicitons d'avoir poussé
avec obstination depuis de nombreuses
années pour l'adoption de la déco jeu du
gaz de la déco égalisation de
l'allocation adulte handicapé mettant
fin à de trop nombreuses années
d'injustice
rappelons que nous avons essayé
à plusieurs reprises et nous avons
essuyé six refus du gouvernement pendant
tout le quinquennat précédent au delà
des revalorisations proposé prestations
familiales minima sociaux retraite de
base point d'un disque qui reste très en
deçà très en deçà de l'inflation
5,8 sur un an qui les estimations ce
texte finalement consacre aussi et
malheureusement la politique libérale de
la prime du chèque
nous regrettons vivement que de très
nombreux amendements portant notamment
sur l'encadrement ou la conditionnalité
de ces dispositions de ces primes de ces
exonérations de cotisations sociales et
été rejetée par les minorités que vous
représentez ce texte surtout contrôler
soigneusement l'augmentation des
salaires que nous réclamons à gauche
depuis longtemps nous avons fait de
nombreuses propositions concrètes avant
même la présentation de cette loi
dès janvier nous défendions
l'augmentation du smic à 1500 euros net
et la nécessaire revalorisation du
travail et la juste répartition de la
valeur créée proposition rejetée par le
gouvernement et les bancs renaissance et
l'air est reine
finalement l'état plutôt que vous
représentez madame la ministre plutôt
que de décider une hausse du smig
finance donc une sorte de complément sur
son budget et donc par l'impôt des
contribuables et notamment des autres
salariés ces primes désocialisés
défiscalisées qui ne bénéficieront au
total qu'une minorité ne facilite même
pas le dialogue social interne aux
entreprises et ne donne vous le savez
bien aucun droit supplémentaire aucune
protection aucune amélioration pérenne
enfin contrairement aux annonces faites
votre méthode d'élaboration de la loi
n'a pas changé aucune modification
substantielle au texte du gouvernement
n'a été réellement adopté
c'est pour cette raison que le groupe
socialiste apparentés ne pourra pas
soutenir ce projet de loi qui n'apporte
pas de réponses sérieuses aux problèmes
de baisse du pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le seul alain rousseau
pour les groupes écologistes
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes
vous êtes pour l'accumulation nous
sommes pour l' équilibre vous êtes pour
le ruissellement nous sommes pour la
solidarité vous êtes pour l'exceptionnel
et nous sommes pour des mesures
structurelles vous êtes pour les primes
nous sommes pour des salaires vous êtes
pour l'ébriété énergétique nous sommes
pour la sobriété vous êtes pour des
miettes nous sommes pour du pain à la
boulangerie et même l'autonomie vous
êtes pour le gaz de schiste et le
charbon et nous sommes pour les énergies
renouvelables au fond fond votre déni
climatique frôle le
climato-scepticisme pardon je suis
fatigué et votre déni social vaut le
mépris
[Applaudissements]
et vous plaît laissez madame rousseau
poursuivre son propos un monde
un monde nous sépare celui de la
lucidité de l'ambition nous voulions une
loi du pouvoir d'achat ambitieuse nous
avons des miettes nous voulions une
transformation écologique nous avons du
co2 je vous le dis si vous faites une
erreur historique notre société va mal
et au fond vous y être totalement
indifférent
[Applaudissements]
merci la mousson
monsieur tanguay pour le rassemblement
national
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
mes yeux c'est vous avez un passion
coupable pour moi maintenant
il va vous poursuivre qui va vous
poursuivre pendant cinq ans mais en tout
cas vous vous n'avez pas poursuivies de
vos efforts la conquête de maigres mais
réelle petit gain de pouvoir d'achat car
nous sommes là en tant que représentant
personnellement des hôtes france dans la
grande tradition de ceux qui se battent
pour que les français est un peu plus
d'argent à la fin du mois même si ce
n'est pas tout l'argent que nous voulons
nous sommes réunis ici grâce à
l'engagement de marine le pen qui la
première ici dans le paysage politique a
été la première à lever la question du
pouvoir d'achat et je le tiens à la
remercier au nom de tous les gens qui à
cette heure là pour se lever pour que le
pays tienne debout
alors alors alors silence alors
c'est du coeur
j'avoue que je chéris ton gré s'il vous
plaît puis avec je pense beaucoup de
grands parmi nous cercueil collecte de
bonbons c'est un guide de shela vie
s'ils veulent aller ross
[Musique]
silence pour la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
un deuxième rendent au deuxième rang
doit s'ouvrir dans quelques heures
ce deuxième tour ça devrait vous plaire
voilà le 7e tour vous admirerez perdu
vous avez voulu un deuxième boulot vers
un troisième vous ne l'avez donné et à
4e nous sommes une nouvelle assemblée le
cinquième tour c'est celui-là il est un
peu raté le 6e
c'est demain c'est le projet de matières
toxiques at il alors
alors
[Applaudissements]
pour accor de gaulle et battante et ont
peu de légèreté
un peu de légèreté à peu un peu un peu
de légèreté après cette nuit ces heurts
qui ont tous été difficile et que je
veux saluer au nom de vous tous dansé
sur les agents
les agents qui ont permis à ces séances
de se tenir au plus tard
les instances du personnel de
l'assemblée
notre milieu de séance
ll l'accord
et même vous et zorgho toi-même d'ascot
même si vous êtes parfois très pénible
[Applaudissements]
vous nous permettez d'être drôle
alors
maintenant soyons sérieux le deuxième
tour le deuxième round pardon
vous ne nous allons nous avons nous
avons une responsabilité
nous avons en responsabilité voter des
mesures
alors c'est un terreau nique s'il vous
plaît
donnons la parole et à monsieur tanguy à
lui seul s'il vous plaît ce sont 110 g
qui minent de minutes dans cette
discussion a été un skate et qui a été
constructif le pense chers collègues de
la majorité présidentielle je pense
chers collègues de l air ses collègues
de l'yonne que nous avons été nous
constructif et que nous avons essayé
d'apporter notre petite pierre même si
vous n'avez pas attendu saisit l'âme à
coup nous avons entendu pour améliorer
le texte nous avons quand même voter vos
mesures pourquoi je les dis car ce qui
compte c'est quand nous rentrons
circonscription nous pouvons dire nous
pouvons dire aux français et les
regarder droit dans les yeux que nous
avons tenté de faire le maximum pour
améliorer leur pouvoir d'achat
maintenant
vous avez refusé d amendement qui aurait
pu être utile je pense à la diminution
par deux des abonnements téléphoniques
dans les zones blanches qui paie pour
les autres je pense à la limite des
frais bancaires qui sont une spoliation
je pense aux tabous des salaires que
vous n'avez pas voulu aborder est que
nous répondrons à la rentrée grâce à
marine le pen en proposant une
proposition loi sur la hausse de 10 %
s'en charge mais maintenant demain nous
allons parler du plfr il sera temps de
parler de deux choses qui n'ont pas été
abordés c'est notamment la baisse de la
fiscalité et la baisse des dépenses
contraintes il faut chers collègues
faire de vraies économies les économies
structurelles pour pouvoir rendre de
l'argent français dès demain j'espère
que nous pourrons le faire ensemble il y
à de nombreuses économies sur les
migrations il y à de nombreuses
économies sur l'union européenne que
nous pouvons faire ensemble pour rendre
de largement france et enfin enfin
demain il fera temps d'aborder le grand
succès de la tva depuis 30 ans dans ce
pays la tva est devenu le soap le soap
injuste leshop spoliateurs de notre
système fiscal il n'est pas juste la td
a n'est pas un impôt juste nous allons
proposer d'en rendre une grande partie
au peuple de france il faut rendre de la
tva au peuple de france et vous ne savez
toujours pas porté et je vous souhaite
une bonne soirée merci
les flics
bien dernière orateurs inscrits
monsieur bazin pour le banquet
républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur bazin
[Musique]
merci madame la présidente
soyons sérieux soyons sérieux face à
l'inflation dont sont victimes nos
concitoyens
des mesures de ce projet vont dans le
bon sens
protection des consommateurs
revalorisation notamment des retraites
baisse des cotisations pour les
travailleurs indépendants
développement de la prime de partage de
la valeur et de l'intéressement même si
les réalités nos petites entreprises
auraient pu être mieux prise en compte
des corrections sont enfin à porter avec
la ddt et conjugale isation la hache et
pour les retraités agricoles élus locaux
nous sommes battus pour concernant
l'énergie
nous payons les mauvais choix de ces
dernières années
cela étant dit des mesures sont prises
pour sécuriser et nous nous en sommes
nous en avons cruellement besoin
nos approvisionnements mais il faudra
aller plus loin demain pour assurer à
l'avenir notre souveraineté énergétique
et apporter une réponse adaptée à nos
électro-intensifs alors en
responsabilité
les républicains voteront pour ce projet
de loi portant mesures d'urgence pour le
pouvoir des français
mais c'est bien insuffisant il faudra
mes chers collègues dès demain le
compléter
place désormais au projet de loi de
finances rectificative
nous demandons avec force une baisse
conséquente du prix des carburants pour
améliorer vraiment le pouvoir d'achat de
tous les français je pense notamment à
ceux qui habitent dans des territoires
et qui ont besoin d'utiliser une voiture
pour vivre et aller au travail
merci monsieur bazin dernière oratrice à
vous de passer au vote madame décor pour
le blues verte et indépendant outre-mer
et territoires
mes chers collègues
livrent les français nous attendent
car nombre d'entre eux sont pris à la
gorge par la montée des prix la montée
des dépenses contraintes les causes sont
connues la guerre en ukraine
principalement qui a déstabilisé nos
économies connectés
ils nous demandent de pouvoir vivre
dignement du fruit de leur travail de
leur pension de retraite
la seule question à laquelle nous devons
répondre
cette loi a meilleurs tels leur vie
les prestations sociales et les
retraites seront revalorisées à 4%
ce n'est pas rien même si cela reste en
deçà de l'inflation
il nous faudra suivre l'évolution des
prix pour éviter que les mesures
adaptées aujourd'hui adopté aujourd'hui
ne soit obsolète demain
s'agissant de la revalorisation du rsa
nous sommes inquiets du poids
supplémentaire pour les départements
nous proposerons des correctifs dans le
collectif budgétaire
je veux évidemment exprimer notre
satisfaction de voir aboutir à combat
ancien celui de la dea conjugale isation
du calcul de l'allocation adulte
handicapé nous l'avions proposé à
plusieurs reprises dans le précédent
quinquennat il était temps que la
majorité le gouvernement entende raison
et se joignent à nous pour ce vote de
justice c'est une victoire collective
est une avancée pour la garantie des
droits des personnes en situation de
handicap pour leur autonomie nous nous
réjouissons aussi de l'adoption de nos
amendements qui restreignent le
plafonnement des loyers en zone rurale
en outre-mer et en corse
là où la dépendance à la voiture est
importante là où les logements sont
insuffisants là où l'inflation des
loyers gallo porte des mesures
d'adaptation s'impose
un mot sur le volet énergétique
il apporte des réponses d'urgence
forcément insatisfaisante la plupart
sont des dérogations permise par la
situation et devons leur estime
je veux vous faire part de plusieurs
alertes la situation des territoires
insulaires et ultramarin nous alarme
dans les outre mer la pauvreté est à 5
et entre 5 et 15 fois plus fréquente que
dans l'hexagone
cela appelle à un renforcement des
mesures les quelques améliorations
adopté à notre initiative ne suffisent
pas la question des salaires et
notamment des bas salaires n'est pas
résolu les primes peuvent être une
réponse d'urgence à tant d'incertitudes
mais tous les travailleurs n'en
bénéficieront pas nous devrons donc
poursuivre la réflexion sur l'évolution
des salaires les négociations des
branches doivent s'accélérer
nous y serons vigilants
en ces temps difficiles je m'interroge
sur la situation précaire des étudiants
des jeunes nous y reviendrons lors du
projet de loi de finances rectificative
enfin gardons à l'esprit que notre
modèle social protecteur a besoin d'être
lui aussi
protégé alimenter cela applique de
garantir son financement
hamon caractérise à nos yeux ce texte
l'urgence en responsabilité notre groupe
a fait le choix de ne pas s'y opposer
car les français nous attendent
bien qu'incomplète pas totalement
satisfaisante ce texte comporte des
mesures qui vont dans le bon sens une
partie de mon groupe donc votre rat en
sa faveur dot exprime plutôt une volonté
d'abstention
merci madame dépens
je vais donc mettre voix le projet de
loi
[Musique]
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos résultat du scrutin
votants 478 exprimé 457 majorité 229
pour 341 contre 116 l'assemblée
nationale a adopté le projet de loi
[Applaudissements]